على مدى ثلاثه ايام مضت لا يزال اسم
الفنان السعودي الراحل طلال مداح من
الاكثر تداولا وتفاعلا على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بعد اعلان المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ عن حفله تكريم الاضخم للراحل واللي
فور اعلانه وتسابق عشرات الفنانين
للمشاركه تكريم صوت الارض ما توقف عند 50
فنان وفنانه من السعوديه ومن الخليج ومن
العالم العربي اللي قرروا المشاركه في
تكريم الفنان الكبير بل تجاوز الامر حتى
جماهير الفنان الراحل الى جماهير بقيه
الفنانين اللي استذكروا اجمل اغاني طلال
والسعاده ابرز محطات الفنيه اللي لا يمكن
حصرها واحنا في تفاعلكم قررنا نذهب للشارع
السعودي في اكثر من مدينه والتقينا بناس
من مختلف الاعمار والجنسيه وسالناهم سؤال
واحد لو قدر لك وشفت طلال في حياته كده
تقول له
[موسيقى]
انا بحب اقول الفنانه طلال لانه اغاني
كانت حلوه جدا وكان نفسي اكون عايشه من
زمان عشان اسمع اغانيه واحضر حفلاته لانه
فنان يعني عظيم
الجميل
اغانيك الخالده الى الان موجوده في قلوبنا
وذاكرتك وصورتك الى الان موجوده اذا شفت
الفنان الله يرحمه طلال مداح تقول اني
احبك اغاني
ذكرتني في الطفوله كثير همم
دائما حلو
بس فنان جميل همم لن يتكرر ابدا كلنا نحبك
يا طلال ااا الصراحه اغانيك في الذاكره
مهما طال الزمن لو كان موجود الان يعني
ودي اقول له اغني لنا زياد يعني انا من
المعجبين فيها دائما
اسمع له دائما احب اغانيه بصراحه لو اني
كنت هالايام والله اني كل يوم راح احضر
حفلات فقدناك صوت الارض اااه كانت فتره
جميله كانت
اغانيك اغاني عشاق همم اتمنى ان شاء الله
يطلع بالوقت قريب فنان قريب منك على الاقل
او في لمحه منك مع اني انا ما اتوقع اني
تكرر صوتك ولا يتكرر احساسك بالغناء
عاشور فاكسرني
حنين
دعونا نستطيع الان معكم الاجابات في نفس
على نفس السؤال من الرياضه
[موسيقى]
وعلى الالحان على كل اغاني كل اللي راسخه
معنا من واحنا صغار الين ما كبرنا وافضل
اغنيه انا احب احبها صراحه ودائما ارددها
تصدق ولا احلف لك بلساني اوصفلك وحابه اني
صراحه اكون حاضر حفله كريمه
جدا
خلال الايام القادمه
اشكرك كذلك تركيا للشيخ
واللي بقدر اقوله الله يرحمك يا طلال مداح
طلال في قلوبنا طلال يعني ملك الاغنيه
السعوديه يعني طلال
طلال والله انه حي ما مات عندنا ابدا
صراحه انا حزين جدا اني ما لحقت عليك
المسرح
ومن اغانيه كثير اللي نحافظ عليها انا
راجع اشوفك
طلال عندما يغني للحب لا يغني للحب هو
يغني بحب هو يعشق الحب ويعرف الحب حتى
اصبح يقدم لنا بطريقه يعجز اي احد عن
تقديمه بالنسبه للحفله والتكريم هذا اقل
شيء هذا اقل شيء الصراحه وكنا ننتظر هذا
الشيء من زمان لكن الحقيقه مبادره موفقه
ومبادره جميله
اكيد انا بنكون من الحاضرين لهذه الحفله
فتحت لنا الفرصه ان شاء الله باذن الله
طلال مداح الله يرحم مالك هنا موجود يشوف
المسيره اللي حاصله الان يشوف التطور اللي
حصل في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الحفلات الغنائيه الموسم همم حدث لا يكرر
كلمه شكر توجه لجميع الفنانين اللي يحيون
الليله اللي ان شاء الله بتكون ليله فريده
من نوعها همم مسيره لا تكرر للفنان الراحل
طلال مداح
[موسيقى]
مش بس الناس بصراحه بتغمرها محبه طلال
مداح حتى الفنانين سواء من الموجودين او
الراحلين لهم قصص لا تعد ولا تحصى مع صوت
الارض من ابرازهم الراحل الكبير ابو بكر
سالم اللي رافق طلال من بدايته وجمعتهم
اعمال خالده حتى يومنا الحاضر خلونا
نستذكر معكم ملامح من العلاقه اللي امتدت
العقود
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا
حبيبي كيف الحال يا حبيبي كيف الحال كل
سنه وانت طيب حبيبي
الله يحفظك حبيبي
[موسيقى]
كثير يعني اختار ما
طيب له كثير ونغنيها انا واياه وهو ياخذ
وهكذا يعني
الاغنيه
يا حبيبي الله يحفظك
[موسيقى]
هدم المبنى
بذاك الحب اللي ساذه امك فين ده اللي حصل
من بعد
ما قضيت عشر سنين يتهدى
[موسيقى]
راح الحبيب
اما رفيق ضرب الفنان الراحل طلال مداح
طوال ثلاثه عقود واحد ابرز من كتلمته على
يده الفنان عبادي الجوهر وجه رساله شكر
صوتيه لرئيس هيئه الترفيه والجوهر اللي
كان اول من اعلن المشاركه في تكريم صوت
الارض اكد انه هذا تسابق من الفنانين
والفنانات للمشاركه هو دليل على اهميه
المكرمه
الله يمسيك بالخير يا ابو ناصر عساك بخير
طمني عن صحتك مو غريب هذا التفاعل من جميع
الفنانين اللي يبدو استعدادا من المشاركه
في هذا الحفل
لفنانه اعطل كثير الاغنيه السعوديه وهذا
حماس على الجميع هو للمكرم وللمكرم فانت
صاحب هذه المبادره الجميله واهتمامك بالكل
نابع من محبتك ودعمك الفن والفنانين شكرا
لكم القلب اخوك عبادي الجوهر
عضه
الابهام مدري نذم مدريني دم ولا ملام
[موسيقى]
يا ليلي
خلي العادم خلى الكلام
[موسيقى]
يا
ليل
احلام
[موسيقى]
او بالعوده لا بدايات طلال مداح الي كانت
بدايات لشعراء كبار في السعوديه والخليج
كان طلال اول من فتح لهم ابواب الشهره
دعونا نتابع مشاهدينا مع بعض هذه الكلمات
للشاعر الامير بدر بن عبد المحسن عن كيف
اصبح طلال ظاهره استثنائيه في تاريخ
الاغنيه العربيه وكيف كانت لحظه التعاون
الاولى بينهم
[موسيقى]
يعني في مطربين كثير موجودين
بس من المستحيل انك تقول هذا ظاهره
يعني ام كلثوم
[موسيقى]
كبير في في في
ظهور بدر بن عبد العزيز
المحطه الاولى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مح
به ع
ظني ابغى ونقول اعرف
مين المحبه
من ابرز اغنيات صوت الارض طلال مداح في
اواخر تجربته الفنيه الواسعه اغنيه بعنوان
خلصت القصه واحنا بنقول انه القصه ما خلصت
يا طلال وكلنا راجعين نشوفك في اغنياتك
باصوات فنانين وفنانات السعوديه والخليج
والعالم العربي في ليله تكريمك المنتظره
الى اللقاء
الله اكبر انا راجع
اشوفه تسيرني
حنيني ليه
[موسيقى]
راجع
عيونك حنين
[موسيقى]
اسال
العنبر
اسال عنه
كثيرا الليالي
تاثير الليالي
[موسيقى]
عليه